I'm Zach young I'm the pastry director
for craveable Hospitality Group I've
been a pastry chef for 12 years today I
am eating cake out of a box
it looks pretty good solid cake spongy I
feel like everyone had this for their
birthday growing up except for me
thanks mom it has a little bit of like
artificial vanilla flavor but I think
that's what cake mix is about the
texture is great its moist
almost like impossibly moist you could
put a dish sponge and layer it with
chocolate frosting and give it to me and
it would look the same this is your base
model box of cake
two and a half it's basic and everyone
can have it
[Music]
aha I'm guessing this is going to be
spice cake it looks good it's springy it
smells spicy flavor is really good it's
not too strong you got like a nice hint
of nutmeg but the cake itself is almost
unnerving ly damp marshy the spice
flavor is good though and the texture
it's oddly crumbly it's warm it reminds
me of fall feast ours
it looks good it looks red that's red
velvet feels nice kind of feels like a
loofah it's like a little dry there
should be a little hint of cocoa in
there the cake isn't overly sweet it
doesn't taste fake it just doesn't
really taste like anything I mean this
is a pretty classic red velvet cake it's
just a vehicle to get cream cheese
frosting into my mouth I'm going to give
it two and a half this cake was trying
really hard but it just didn't live up
to its potentials
[Music]
like a latte this looks great it looks
chocolatey it smells really nostalgic
like the inside of the bag of tootsie
rolls which i think is a good thing
she's a sturdy cake
she's a thick cake it tastes like cheap
Halloween candy but honestly I kind of
like that I pretend to be sophisticated
but I'm really garbage I just wish the
cake were a little bit more rich three
stars it's a chocolate cake guys how can
it be bad
[Music]
she's dense it didn't really rise
there's no webbing it doesn't look
spongy if you can mess up making a box
cake mix it's not you it's the cake mix
oh yeah it's chewy like nougat gummy has
no place in a cake the flavor is really
good it tastes like real vanilla real
butter if this had been light and airy
this would have been phenomenal I'm
gonna have to give this cake half a star
flavors great the texture needs some
help there is no shame in the box it's
quick and easy and the results are
delicious but honestly it takes just
about the same amount of time to make a
cake from scratch if you have the right
recipe the results are way more
delicious I encourage you to step
outside of the box especially when it
comes to cake or of course you can
support your local pastry chefs and go
buy some of their cakes shameless [ __ ]
[Music]